Chicken Little (A version of the tale by TheFableCottage.com)
Let me tell you a story about a chicken.
His name is Chicken Little.
He lives in a normal little chicken house in a normal little town. Chicken Little is neither tall nor short.
He is neither fat nor thin. He is neither smart nor stupid. He is a completely normal chicken.
One completely normal morning, Chicken Little is eating his breakfast in the kitchen.
He likes toast with butter and coffee with cream. He is reading the internet. He sees a terrifying story with a terrifying headline.
It says: THE SKY IS FALLING! He is so scared that he drops his toast into his coffee.
PLOP!
"The sky is falling?" "THE SKY IS FALLING!" shouts Chicken Little.
"I have to warn everyone!" First, he emails the story to one-thousand of his closest friends.
Then runs down the road to warn everyone else. The first person he meets on the road is Gwen the Hen.
She is coming from the supermarket. "Good morning, Chicken Little!" says Gwen the Hen.
"Where are you going? Why are you so scared?" "The sky is falling! THE SKY IS FALLING!" says Chicken Little.
"Really? How do you know?" asks Gwen. "I saw it on the internet!" says Chicken Little.
"Holy moly! It must be true!" says Gwen.
"Let's go!" And so Chicken Little and Gwen the Hen run down the road towards the pond.
When they reach the pond, they meet Chuck the Duck. He is having a bath. "Hello, you two!" says Chuck the Duck.
"Where are you going? Why are you so scared?" "The sky is falling! The sky is falling!" say Chicken Little and Gwen the Hen together.
"Really? How do you know?" asks Chuck. "I saw it on the internet!" says Chicken Little.
"Oh no! It must be true!" says Chuck. "Let's go!" So Chicken Little, Gwen the Hen, and Chuck the Duck run down the road towards the farm.
When they reach the farm they meet Bruce the Goose. He is reading poetry to Percy the pigeon.
"Hello everyone!" says Bruce the Goose.
"Where are you going? Why are you so scared?" "The sky is falling. THE SKY IS FALLING!" everyone yells.
"Really? How do you know?" asks Percy the pigeon. "WE SAW IT ON THE INTERNET!!" they all say.
"Goodness gracious! It must be true!" says Bruce.
"There is no time to read poetry now. Let's go!" And Chicken Little, Gwen the Hen, Chuck the Duck, Bruce the Goose and Percy the Pigeon run down the road towards the town.
On the main street, they meet Fred the Fox. He is sitting at a cafe, writing on his laptop.
"Hello everyone!" says Fred the Fox.
"Where are you going? Why are you so scared?" "THE SKY IS FALLING! THE SKY IS FALLING!" everyone yells.
"Really? How do you know?" asks Fred. "WE SAW IT ON THE INTERNET!!!!" they all shout.
"Wow! Well then it must be true!" says the fox.
"But don't worry, friends, I know the perfect place to hide. Follow me!"
Fred the fox leads everyone through the village, down the road, across the field, and up a hill.
At the top of the hill is a big, dark cave. "Come in! Come in!" says Fred the fox.
"There is enough room for everybody! The sky won't fall on us here. We are safe."
And so, one by one, Chicken Little and all of his friends follow the fox into the cave.
The next morning, Chicken Little and his friends have disappeared. The cave is empty. Where did they go?
We don't know for sure.
But I will tell you one thing: Fred the Fox is very happy. He has a big, round belly.
"Silly animals," he says.
And he sits under a tree, gets his laptop, and begins to write again.